I love facebook
spam spam spam for meal thing spam spam
Oh more across sent me a friend request
you
can I be on your show come on it's me
Big Daddy you know I'm really funny I'm
not doing anything um nothing not
listening there's known here beside me
wait I'm getting a message from Isaac
especially not when he's in the 7-eleven
that's being robbed dillhole well I
could get out of here because I just
broke in to use the computer or I could
just sit here for the next seven hours
what computer error what
hey samus it's time to go home what are
you doing oh crap did you download that
virus again
curse you Microsoft
give her soul back machine eat iphone or
selesai iphone eats you hey how'd you
kill that thing what do you mean how did
I kill it you know what juice these
freaking things take a lot a lot
I don't even know where to start about
how much this phone sucks the batteries
take up more than Las Vegas they call
that the City of Light plus it's made by
apple and that's never good that in and
of itself is its first flaw because
Apple is the worst how did I just get
shot anyway listen to this ringtone
it's a corporate Jim Carrey from
freaking dumb and dumber I don't even
know how it got here nor do I know how
to get it off I hate this so much ah mr.
jobs that's a negative on the kill